hall of fame head coach tony dungey
joined me yesterday on the pft pm
podcast i went down to my barn and hung
out there where we have been doing the
pftpn podcast in recent weeks and the
big topic of discussion the proposed
enhancements to the rooney rule which
will
change the rule that's been on the books
for 18 years the rule on the books
requires teams to interview at least one
minority candidate for coaching and
general manager jobs this takes it a lot
farther than that actually rewarding
teams that hire coaches and general
managers who are minorities with boosted
draft standing the year after the hire
is made it's been a controversial
measure and i wanted to get coach
dungy's thoughts on it here is an
extended clip from monday's discussion
with hall of fame head coach tony dungy
give me your thoughts personally on
whether this is the right move whether
it maybe doesn't go far enough or
whether it goes too far
yeah i i think that this is definitely
something that that's been
looked at and said we've got to do
something drastic
in my mind this is drastic i don't
personally think it's the right thing to
do but i think it should spur some uh
really consideration and some
communication and conversation and
people say okay this might not be it but
maybe we can do that i just have never
been in favor of
rewarding people for doing the right
thing and and so i think there's going
to be some unintended consequences to me
it's almost like the past interference
rule yeah we need to do something i
don't know if this is exactly it we need
to keep working until we find out what
that best thing is to do i've talked to
several uh
african-american coaches in in the
league right now to get their response
and here's there's three things that
they're worried about number one how
does this put me in my relationship with
the other coaches that i work with and
other white coaches are they thinking
i'm getting an advantage now number two
when that general manager or owner hires
me is he hiring me because he thinks i'm
the best person or is he hiring me to
move his draft choice up a little bit uh
and then the third thing is nobody feels
like they want anything special an
advantage don't hire me and then say i'm
going to give you more draft choices
later on because you need help or you
know and i know that's not the reason
why the proposal is being put in i know
that's not
you know what they're driving at but
that's still the end result and so uh
there there's some things i think the
league needs to think about about this
proposal it's different from that
inherently competitive
32 teams everyone wanting to draft as
high as possible and get the best
possible picks and you are moving some
down moving some up and also and you're
touching on one of the concerns that
lewis riddick shared with peter king in
football morning in america the idea
that as you walk through the door people
may be viewing you differently you are
undermined before you even start the job
because there's this sense that some may
have that the only reason you're getting
the job is because the team derives some
tangible benefit from hiring a minority
gm or coach
yeah and there there is i think the
league is looking and saying hey
punitive things haven't worked let's
look at incentives and maybe that's the
right way to go but i don't know if this
is the right incentive if you had a vote
it sounds like your vote would be no
which i think
should speak volumes to anyone out there
who has a vote on tuesday on this
proposal
i
when i looked at it i didn't see how it
would pass a lot of people are telling
me that it will i think if it does pass
it'll end up being like the past
interference
review rule we'll see
in a little while some some unintended
consequences that will say gosh this
this might not be the best
idea that's coach tony dungy some very
candid thoughts on a proposal that will
be voted on today by the league's 32
owners as they engage in a virtual
meeting it's their first meeting since
the pandemic began and just like with
replay review for pass interference
chris i mean we know that's going away
but without an in-person meeting i think
it's hard to have the right discussion
as to a replacement for past
interference replay review i'm not sure
they can have the right discussion in a
virtual setting for how best to handle
the proposed changes to the rooney rule
and obviously this is the most
controversial the idea that there is a
tangible draft pick benefit to making an
actual hire not just complying with the
rule and and interviewing a minority
candidate but taking it that step
farther and if coach dungey's opposed to
it folks i think that it makes sense for
the owners to think twice
and three times and maybe four times
before voting for this and the problem
is there is a a sense chris that they're
pushing hard somebody's pushing hard
whether it's a league office whether
it's a group of owners there's a
determination to get this passed a lot
of lobbying is happening to get it
passed and i i hope everyone takes a
step back and listen to what coach
dungey had to say before making their
final decision
i i agree you know first off i agree
with everything tony dungy said i mean i
really do he's so smart he's so well
thought out you know the biggest point i
just feel like it would diminish the
qualifications of some african-american
coaches who would be a head coach of an
nfl team yeah you'd have the haters of
the world out there oh he wouldn't be a
head coach if it weren't for the fact
that they got a better draft pick or all
that
let alone i think it is very real that
it will cause resentment in the nfl
coaching world you know to me again and
there is a huge issue here we know that
i mean the fact that to me hey come on
the fact that eric b enemy is not a head
coach after it's been the best offense
in football for two years in a row just
speaks volumes to where we are at in
this league there is a color problem in
the coaching world in the nfl there is
no doubt it's been entrenched in white
world for a long long time and i don't
mean that in a racist sense i just mean
in the fact that hey you know
it's
the nfl it's got a lot of old school
white businessmen front office men
coaches they bring their families or
other people they know that they're
connected with into the football
organization into the football world
that takes up more spots for maybe other
young black african-american men that
are qualified to me mike this is where
it has to start and just in my
experience and coaching and being around
it it has to start at the bottom in the
nfl like oh hey hey uh the new york
giants are hiring equality control oh
he's white okay he's white then we have
to hire a black quality control coach
too oh we're hiring a scouting assistant
you know hey it's uh mr kraft's lawyer's
son because we're bringing him in
because that's what the whole league is
full of these people that are connected
to the rich and powerful of the league
oh we're bringing him in okay well we
also have to bring in a young
african-american scouting assistant it
has to start funneling from the bottom
to me instead of just looking to make
big time hires at the head coaching
position i think you know that's to me
the one area jumps out uh i don't think
you can force organizations or a
business owner to hire somebody
uh because of the skin color or make it
not look so good because of the the
draft pick compensation
well i i agree with you i and and it is
a problem that requires much deeper
thought and discussion than simply
dangling a carrot see the problem is
they've tried the stick for 18 years
they've tried the punishment the thou
shout you must do the interviews and we
have seen teams bend over backwards to
check the box it's not about
actually expanding the search it's not
about slowing it down that's one of the
things coach dungy has preached and
there could be further changes to the
hiring process that will force owners to
slow it down that's also part of what
coach dungey spoke about yesterday and
i've heard that separately that what
we've heard about as it relates to this
proposal that's received so much of the
discussion is just just a sliver of what
else may be coming and slowing down the
process may be part of it and requiring
owners to understand exactly what
they're looking for coach dungy spent
time talking about how
there's value in having owners develop a
list of factors what are you looking for
and maybe the guy you have has all the
things you're looking for maybe you
don't even need to make a change if you
do need to make a change be guided by
the factors not by oh this guy won a
super bowl five years ago and he's
available this is the guy i want and
we've seen so many times chris where an
owner gets smitten with a candidate
months before the season ends like dan
snyder with mike shanahan this is the
guy i have to hire this is the guy i
have to hire there's no way you're going
to have a diverse inclusive search when
the owner decides months before the
season has concluded that this is the
guy he's going to hire
that's right i think that's where it
really gets tricky and i think again
those are the points why i think it
could cause a lot of resentment in the
coaching world and really put
african-american coaches who are very
qualified to be a head coach really put
them in a tough spot to where like what
coach dungy said you know people are
going to be looking at them at the
corner of their eye you know as they
walk in did he really earn this or is he
getting it because of you know some rule
or whatever it may be you know to me
this is a systemic issue you know and
again it's not it's not about racism or
anything racism or anything about that
uh it might be a little but i just think
it's such a you know
a culture of family and connections and
things like that and the culture yeah if
you go back to the history of the nfl of
course is more white than black but you
know again look at all the coaches and
their family and their sons that are
involved in the nfl all over the place
you know and of course yes coaches it
was a more of a a white society in the
70s and 80s so now those coaches who got
their sons and other people and their
family involved in it and of course
they're white to go along with it and
that just doesn't give any room for
growth there that's to me the biggest
issue i see you know it has become a
sport that is very popular it's become
very political and it's become more
about who you know instead of what you
know and that is a real issue to me and
it bothers me mike you know i see it
anywhere i go to a building in training
camp oh how did that kid get a job oh
his friends with the dad you know his
dad's friends with the owner his dad's
friends with the gm has he ever played
football has he ever even been involved
in anything football no he's not but now
he's running the scouting department
whoa okay so that to me is one of the
biggest issues that's you have to start
from the bottom and start grooming some
diversity there and then i think you'll
start to see more hires of color and
african-american coaches
well and here's the other reality too as
there is an increased representation of
minority coaches and gm's the cronyism
and the nepotism is going to swing the
other way as well i don't think you can
get rid of the cronyism and the nepotism
but no you can't sure that for the for
the big hires there is a more careful
deliberate process and there is part of
this proposal aimed at at
ensuring that there is a better pipeline
of minority candidates and that speaks
to what you're saying at the bottom of
the industry as guys are entering and
and females are now entering are the
opportunities there to grow and develop
and be groomed to become a coach that's
the one thing folks lose sight of a lot
of the people who eventually become head
coaches have been groomed to become head
coaches who gets chosen who stands out
from that crowd of the young coaches as
somebody that's like ah ah this is the
person who's gonna be groomed you need
to be in that group to have a chance to
be somebody who stands out and gets put
on that track to becoming a head coach
so these are these are issues that
require further thought further
discussion for the deliberation and
that's one of my big takeaways as we get
ready for this meeting today that the
owners will be conducting virtually
the hiring cycle doesn't begin tomorrow
folks there's no reason to adopt these
rules now you know anytime there is a a
proposal that's been fast-tracked and
they're trying to jam it through that
tells me that somebody doesn't want
everyone to understand all the issues
they just want what they want we got to
jam this through well how about we just
press pause on it and say ain't nobody
hiring a head coach today or tomorrow or
next week barring some dramatic turn of
events that we would not anticipate as
part of the normal hiring process we
have months to figure out what the rules
will be for the next hiring process why
in the world does this proposal have to
get pushed through today if there are
voices like tony dungey's who are lining
up against it all right let's take a
break by the way the full podcast
available at the pft pm podcast wherever
you get your podcast and it's available
on youtube and we'll be dropping links
to the
audio and the video at
profootballtalk.com
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports